[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: So this is the
150th anniversary celebration
interview with Professor
Isadore Singer.
And let me start by asking,
where you were born?
Where'd you grow up?
SINGER: I was born
in Detroit, Michigan.
I'll start over again.
INTERVIEWER: Okay.
SINGER: Where was I born?
I was born in Detroit, Michigan,
in 1924, and I grew up there.
My parents came from Poland and
emigrated to Toronto, Canada,
where they met and married.
And then they came
to Detroit in 1923.
INTERVIEWER: And what
did your parents do?
Did they also work?
SINGER: My father was a printer
and my mother a seamstress.
When they arrived, my
father tells a story
that the printers'
union was on strike.
And they asked him not
to break the strike
and gave him $5 a day not
to do that, and he agreed.
He wrote his mother
back in Poland
that it is, in fact, true
that the streets of the United
States were paved with gold.
We were very poor
during the Depression.
It's a vivid memory
for me, and so I'm
particularly concerned about
people who are out of jobs
now, because my father was
out of a job for a year or so.
And we suffered
badly at that time.
INTERVIEWER: Were there any
particular events or influences
in your childhood that you think
helped you to choose the career
path you chose?
SINGER: No.
You know, I was an all-A
student all the time.
Mostly, I found school boring.
I preferred playing baseball
and stuff like that.
I was more interested
in athletics
than I was in anything
going on at school.
I read a great deal.
Things did come to an end about
my junior year in high school.
I had a very good
English teacher,
and I had a very good
chemistry teacher.
So a periodic table struck me
as something very exciting,
and the English teacher got me
to read lots of good books--
Dostoyevsky, War and Peace.
My oldest daughter's
named Natasha
after Natasha in War and Peace.
So those two things
had a big impact on me
and woke me up to the
excitement of science.
I became president of the
Science Club very quickly
and gave lectures on
relativity already
as a senior in high school.
INTERVIEWER: How did you decide
on the University of Michigan?
SINGER: They had a
competition, and I either
came first or second
in this competition,
and therefore, I
won a scholarship
to the University of Michigan.
What that meant was
I had tuition paid.
Tuition was $50 a semester.
As I say, we were very
poor, and I was originally
going to go to Wayne
University and live at home.
But my mother said, you can't.
You can't give up
$50 twice a year.
So I went to
Michigan as a result.
I lived in a co-op.
In the co-op I lived
in, you paid $2.25
a week for room and board.
And I remember the vivid
discussion about getting up
to $2.50 a week, which we did.
INTERVIEWER: It must
be staggering to look
at tuition prices now.
SINGER: Absolutely.
It's shocking, actually.
But of course, there are a
lot of amenities that one
doesn't take into account.
We didn't have any at all.
In fact, I survived by having
three jobs at any one time
and also by selling
my football tickets,
which I could sell
illegally for $5 a ticket.
That lasted two weeks for me.
At any rate, the war started
when I was a freshman.
And I enlisted in
the Signal Corps,
because they said they would
allow me to continue school
until I finished, as
long as I took courses
in electrical
engineering, which I did.
Because they wanted me to
become a radar officer when
I finally got in the army.
I might add that I rushed
through school because I didn't
really believe that they would
let me go the full four years,
and I got my degree
in 2 and 1/2 years.
INTERVIEWER: That must
have been difficult.
SINGER: Well, I've gotten
used to being at MIT,
with everything going on
and so many things to do.
INTERVIEWER: So what is it
that drew you to physics,
do you think?
SINGER: Because of my lectures
on relativity in high school,
I felt that I didn't
really understand
the question what the issue was,
even though I spoke about it.
And so I wanted to learn more
about relativity, and I I'd
heard about quantum mechanics.
And so I wanted to
learn that, as well.
Actually, when I
got to Michigan,
I hadn't decided whether
to major in physics
or in English literature.
And what happened
was that I found
students in the poetry
class understood poetry,
many of them,
instinctively, easily,
and I struggled with it.
But when I took
physics, I was the one
who understood what was
going on very quickly,
and that decided me as to
what path I should take.
INTERVIEWER: That's a good
way to make the decision.
SINGER: That's what I think
the first couple of years
at a university is all about.
INTERVIEWER: And then how
did the interests shift
from physics to math?
SINGER: That's kind
of complicated.
As I say, I finished
early, went into the army.
Was in the army for
2 and 1/2 years.
But after a year and a half,
when I was destined for
was greater officer in
the European sector.
And that was about
ended, and we were all
moved to go to the Pacific.
I was still concerned
that, as an undergraduate,
I didn't understand relativity
or quantum mechanics.
And I had heard about
extension courses
at the University of Chicago.
So on my way, everybody--
it was called redeployment
at that time, all of us
moving from the East Coast
to the West.
I stopped in Chicago and
went up to the fourth floor
of the building.
And there was-- I've
forgotten his name.
[INAUDIBLE], I think.
At any rate, he told me he
did have extension courses
in geometry and then
group theory, which was
needed for quantum mechanics.
And so I enrolled in them,
and I took them with me.
I ended up in the
Philippines and ended up
running a communications
school for the Filipino army
when I was out there.
And I would get
these letters from--
corrected papers of mine.
I studied all the time.
My friends played poker,
and I did my homework.
But to answer your
question, how did
I get into math,
what happened was
since all the textbooks for
these correspondence courses
were from the
University of Chicago,
I thought that would
be the place to go.
And I was, indeed, accepted
in the math department,
because I thought I wanted
more math to understand
the physics of quantum mechanics
and relativity, which was,
in fact, the right instinct.
But that first year in math was
so wonderful and so beautiful,
whereas listening in on the
quantum mechanics course,
it was still the same--
a rough course, I would say.
Then I felt mathematics
was really my field.
And I was right, because it was
a mathematical instinct that
told me the way they were
teaching quantum mechanics
was not right.
That is, in fact, true
as far as I'm concerned.
INTERVIEWER: You decided to stay
at the University of Chicago
for your doctorate.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: Why?
SINGER: Well, that first
year was so wonderful.
And remember, I didn't have
a great background in math.
But a lot of friends
supported me and taught me
the material I didn't know.
I rapidly caught up.
And the faculty was
just terrific there.
Brought new people in--
Andre Weil, one of the
world's great mathematicians.
Chern, SS Chern, came the last
year, who influenced me greatly
in differential geometry.
And we became very good friends
over a long period of time.
So that was the place to be.
INTERVIEWER: So would you
consider him a mentor?
SINGER: My two mentors
were Chern, certainly,
and Irving Segal, who
was my thesis advisor
and eventually came to MIT.
I learned a great deal
from both of them.
INTERVIEWER: I wonder if
you'd talk a little bit more
about Irving Segal?
SINGER: About Irving Segal?
INTERVIEWER: Mm-hmm.
SINGER: Well, he was a
wonderful and lousy teacher
at the same time.
We were excited
about what he was
doing, because he was lecturing
on the forefront of analysis
and functional analysis.
But he got stuck about
halfway through every lecture,
and he spent the rest
of the lecture trying
to straighten it out.
So that makes him
a lousy teacher.
He didn't get very
far in any one day.
But I'd go home and
would try and solve
the problem he was stuck with.
And I'd either have my solution
or I didn't know how to do it,
so I was very eager
to see what he
was going to do at the
next meeting in the class.
And I could compare my solution
with his, if I had one,
or I could see where
he did something
that I hadn't understood.
And so it was essentially
doing research every time
on your own.
So that's one way in which he
was a very exciting teacher.
Also, he stayed late at night.
And most of us, as students,
stayed late at night.
His door was always open.
So late at night, I
could go in, and it
wasn't a matter of talking
about my dissertation.
If we did, that was
for about five minutes.
But we'd spend the rest
of the time talking
about mathematics
and the importance
of functional analysis.
So that's how he
influenced me a great deal
and gave me a very good
background in analysis.
Chern came the last
year I was there.
And his field is
differential geometry.
And I only listened to
his course and took notes,
but I immediately felt that
I was in the wrong field,
I was so taken by
his geometric view
and the instruments
he used in order
to reflect that geometric view.
And it was too late for
me to make any changes,
but you'll see that it had a
great impact on me and on MIT
when we get to it.
INTERVIEWER: So how
did you come to MIT?
SINGER: Well, when I got my
degree, I had two offers.
One to the Institute for
Advanced Study to be with--
what's the matter with me?
I've forgotten.
And MIT, I had an offer.
And that offer was
$50 more than the one
from the Institute
for Advanced Study.
So, naturally, I took it.
I had a family already, and
that was the thing to do.
INTERVIEWER: Do you remember
what your first impressions
were of MIT?
SINGER: I'm so glad you asked
me about my first impression.
So you said you liked
stories, and I'm
going to tell you one
I've often spoke about.
In fact, I'm going to reminisce,
because I'm retiring June 30th.
And I arrived at
MIT July 1, 1950.
So that's 60 years,
with some time away.
But July 1, we'll
celebrate the 60 years,
and I'm about to tell
you the first day.
So I came over across--
I was staying in Back Bay--
across the river and
went to Building 2
to meet Ted Martin,
who was the chairman.
And he had one
secretary, Ruth Goodwin.
Went into the office.
There was a guy
reading The Globe.
And I told Ruth who I was.
He put down his paper
and said, I'm Ambrose.
Singer, we've got a seminar
going on Lie groups.
Come on, let's go.
I said, but I have to
see Professor Martin.
He said, oh, that'll keep.
Come on.
So I went to the
seminar, and I met
a number of people who
got to be good friends,
some mathematicians of note.
George White,
particularly, in topology.
And then we went back and
I did talk to the chair,
and Ambrose waited for me.
And then he said, we meet
for coffee at 11:00 PM.
I'll pick you up.
Where do you stay?
So he did pick me up
that night around 11:00,
and we went to this
terrible coffee shop--
Hayes Bickford in the
middle of nowhere in Boston.
And there, I met the same
group who were in the seminar.
And Kate Whitehead,
George Whitehead's wife,
was there, and also
a mathematician.
And we talked for a bit.
And then I thought Ambrose
was going to take me home.
He did not.
He simply showed me
what Boston was about,
drove around for a long time,
and dropped me off about 3:00
in the morning.
And I went up to
this apartment that I
had been given for a few days.
You have to remember
that I hadn't been home,
because I'd left
for the university.
I then spent three
years in the army,
and I then spent 3 and 1/2 years
at the University of Chicago,
so I really had no home.
I went up to my bedroom
and said, I'm home.
This is my home.
And that's my first day at MIT.
INTERVIEWER: Do you remember--
so you had had experience
at two other universities.
Was there anything that
struck you as different
when you got on the
campus and kind of got
to know the students and the
faculty and the culture here?
SINGER: Not immediately,
but as time went on,
I saw a considerable difference
between the two places.
One of the important
things at Chicago
was it was a graduate school.
For us, undergraduate
teaching was
done by another division
of the university.
As a graduate student, we saw
very little of undergraduates,
brilliant as they were.
I would mostly see
them in the locker room
or in some sport
or another and had
very little contact with them.
I did no teaching there.
MIT was entirely different.
It was an important and
enormous load or responsibility
of teaching undergraduates.
And that has been done
with great aplomb,
as far as I'm concerned.
So MIT was a place
where you did research,
but teaching was
extremely important.
INTERVIEWER: Was there
anything about it
that was a surprise
when you've sort of got
to know undergraduates?
SINGER: Was there
a surprise at MIT?
INTERVIEWER: Either
in their attitude
or what you found you
got from the relationship
or anything like that?
SINGER: Well, it took a while
for me to think in those terms,
I must say.
What happened was that
Ambrose asked me what
Chern had done in his course.
And he wanted me to discuss it
and explain it to everybody.
He was a stickler for details.
So I ended up more or less
lecturing on differential
geometry to him,
learning it with him,
and reorganizing it into
a more modern language
than Chern used.
We gave courses in it.
Students wrote books about it.
And so MIT became a center
for a differential geometry
on the basis of what we
tried to do with, really,
the notes of my
course from Chicago.
Now, as to the difference,
the feeling that I had
was that I could--
there was a kind of freedom.
I could give a course
immediately on new material
to undergraduates.
And recently, in fact, because I
was looking for some old notes,
I was really shocked at how much
large undergraduate teaching I
did at the time with the freedom
of reorganizing the course.
I gave a course in-- it was
called Algebra Matrix Theory,
and I just changed it
completely into a modern form.
And I still have former
students who are now well-known
mathematicians who remind
me, whenever we meet,
that I had given this remarkable
course with a huge audience--
2190, the big room.
I gave lectures in
there frequently,
and I was allowed to do that--
criticized, of course,
by some old timers.
But there was a freedom
to change courses.
So as to adapt to modern times.
I must tell you
that the '50s was
a period of great
development in mathematics.
And so between seminars,
reorganizing courses,
and keeping up with
what was happening--
topology, geometry.
A lot of things were
happening at that time.
We had many seminars.
We could immediately put
them in the coursework,
and we were allowed a freedom
to do that that I had not known
before, but only
because I wasn't--
you know, I couldn't
do that at Chicago,
because I was a student.
Whereas, here, I wasn't
a student anymore.
And that was really--
those were exciting times.
INTERVIEWER: Is there
a particular reason
the '50s was such a busy
time for mathematics?
SINGER: Yeah, because
the war ended.
INTERVIEWER: Just
the influx of people?
SINGER: Well,
there were a number
of very good French
mathematicians
who were prisoners of war
or conscientious objectors,
and they were one of the
leaders in this development.
So we got a lot of new
stuff coming out of France.
And then there was Chern
and what he was doing
and what he had done and
the implications of it.
So a lot of things were
happening that were brand new.
The '50s were very special.
INTERVIEWER: So
can we sort of walk
through the various
areas of interest
that you've had over
the years, starting
with differential geometry?
Will you talk about the
work you've done in that
and maybe why it's particularly
interesting to you,
why it's captured
your attention?
SINGER: I think
what I really like
in mathematics is
the connections
between different fields.
And geometry
captured my attention
because it combined topology
with geometric insight.
And you needed analysis, which
I learned from Irving Segal,
in order to--
well, what we call in order
to get existence theorems.
In order to solve certain
equations which came up
from geometry, you needed
some strength in analysis
in order to solve
those equations.
And I like that combination
of all three things,
and that's what
attracted me to geometry.
And in fact, again,
what we did at MIT
was all the courses that
needed these backgrounds
in other fields,
Ambrose and I revised.
And we revised the geometry
course, as well, to be modern.
And I think, among them
all, the geometry course
is pretty much what it
was when we revised them--
by then, the '60s.
INTERVIEWER: I assume they had
not been revised for a while
before that.
SINGER: That's right.
They were pretty old-fashioned.
This was an opportunity of
Young Turks coming in and doing
some new things.
INTERVIEWER: It
was your impression
that the mathematics department
was a little behind the times
when you arrived?
SINGER: I don't know.
The only department I had been
acquainted with was Chicago,
and it certainly was
not behind the times.
I guess maybe MIT was a
little and we were the first--
Ambrose was the
leader, I must say.
It was his energy that said
we should do this, that,
and the other thing.
And I provided some of the
energy to help him along.
And so it did need
some modernization
in the '50s, though we had
terrific people like George
Whitehead.
And Norbert Wiener
was still there,
but he was doing his own thing.
And his main contributions
to mathematics
were already finished by then.
INTERVIEWER: Well, that's
probably why they hired you.
SINGER: Pardon?
INTERVIEWER: That's
probably why they hired--
bring someone the University
of Chicago newer stuff to MIT.
SINGER: Well, it took
a while, you know?
I always kid the department.
They had a program of
instructors, Moore instructors,
and I was a Moore instructor
there from '50 to '52.
But they did not keep me on.
It was only supposed to
be a two-year appointment,
and most of us left.
And I went to UCLA.
But I say they sent me to the
minor leagues for training,
and they did.
And it was good
for me, actually,
and I came back
four years later.
And that's really when I
started revising the department.
And I think Ambrose and
Whitehead, who were here,
were very eager to
have me come back,
and that's why the department
decided to have me come back.
INTERVIEWER: What about the
area of partial differential
equations?
SINGER: That's part of
what I call analysis,
and those equations are
what come up in differential
geometry many times.
And it's solving
those equations that
are critical for many
problems in geometry.
INTERVIEWER: And I have
mathematical physics?
SINGER: Yes, that came later.
Mathematical
physics-- my interest
in mathematical physics
started with something
called self-dual solutions, to
partial differential equations.
And those self-dual
equations were much simpler
than the usual ones you find
in what's called gauge theory.
And I was struck by the
physicists Polyakov and company
coming up with these geometric
solutions to equations.
And we mathematicians
had not seen them.
And I felt that it was
a blind spot on our part
not to have understood
that these equations could
be simplified this way.
And then I got interested
in saying, well,
why do they want these?
What's happening?
And this has to do with what's
called gauge theory in physics,
which turns out to be
something of mathematics--
fiber bundles that
we knew in geometry.
So I was struck by what
they had done, struck
about this dictionary called
the Wu-Yang Dictionary, that
related mathematical terms
in geometry to physics
terms in gauge theory.
And so I wanted to know where
all this was leading to,
and I started to
seminar and a course
on the connections
between math and physics.
Now, I did not do that here.
In '77, I decided,
for personal reasons,
to go to the West Coast,
and I went to Berkeley.
And I spent seven
years at Berkeley.
MIT was not happy about
that, and what they did
is ask me to retire and make
sure that I could return easily
and come out of retirement.
So I started the
seminar in Berkeley.
And every year, I
got a call from MIT
to ask me to come back.
And I got very
impatient with Berkeley.
And when they made the critical
call, I said, yes, I'm coming.
I'm coming home.
And I did.
INTERVIEWER: What was
different about the atmosphere
or culture at Berkeley
that didn't fit
as well as the MIT one?
SINGER: As I said, I went
there for personal reasons,
not for scientific reasons.
But there, I did witness
a change in culture.
It's as if the
younger people felt
that there were some connections
between math and physics
that hadn't been
explored, and they
were excited about my running
a course and giving a seminar.
And three of my
best students are
students that I
had at Berkeley who
got involved in this
connection between geometry
and mathematics and
case theory and physics,
wrote her thesis
about these matters.
And all three of them are
very close friends who I know.
INTERVIEWER: So why did you
ultimately decide to come back?
SINGER: Berkeley, politically,
I didn't care for mixture.
And the University, although
it had some brilliant people,
by and large, there were people
who were still involved in--
I don't know-- revolutionary
times, political issues.
And they had more to
say at the University
than the really brilliant
people who were there.
And ultimately, I got impatient
with all that politics
interfering with real science.
And it was one of
those days where
I was fuming that MIT
called me again and asked
me to come back, and I did.
INTERVIEWER: Is this a good
time to talk about your theorem
and how that came about?
SINGER: Yes.
But I'd like to have one more--
we're talking about stories.
My wife and two daughters were
very unhappy about moving east.
And they always said that they
wanted to go back, especially
my children, my two daughters.
Well, it now happens
that daughter Emily
is biotech editor of
technology reviews here,
and my other daughter,
Annabel, received her PhD
in brain and cognitive sciences
at the University of California
San Francisco and elected
to be a postdoc here at MIT.
So now they're both here,
and I see them frequently.
INTERVIEWER: So you
knew best after all.
SINGER: I wouldn't know,
but it's worked out.
INTERVIEWER: So how did your
collaboration and your theorem
develop?
Can you tell me that story?
SINGER: Yes.
I got to know
Michael Atiyah when
I was at the Institute for
Advanced Study in 1955.
That was a very good year.
We had a lot of top
mathematicians there,
and I got to know Michael well.
And there was a change in
my family circumstances,
and I was on sabbatical.
And I needed to go to someplace
where English was spoken.
And so I called Michael.
He himself had just
arrived at Oxford,
and I asked whether
there was a place for me.
And he simply said, come.
We'll arrange it.
So my wife and I and
son moved to Oxford.
And after I got settled
in the first day,
I was warming myself
by one of those fires.
And he came up and he
asked me a question, which
was a question in his field.
Why was the A-roof genus an
integer for spin manifolds?
That was the question.
And I looked at him
and I said, Michael,
why are you asking
me that question?
You know the answer to that.
Really probing him that
he had some other reason
for asking it.
He said, well, yes,
I do know the answer.
But I feel there's a
deeper reason for it.
I liked that answer.
And although I was working
on another problem,
I spent the spring in the
gardens of Oxford colleges
sitting on benches thinking
about that problem.
And finally, I thought
I knew the answer to it.
And it involved the Dirac
operator, Dirac's equation
for a spinning electron, which
I knew for other reasons,
and involved
differential equations
and analysis and some geometry.
So the next day, I came to
Michael's office and said,
look, Michael, I think
you're getting an integer
because it's the number of
solutions to this equation.
Moreover, if we do a
little bit of juggling,
you'll see that all the
equations that give you
integers as answers can
all be described in terms
of these geometric operators.
You're just counting
the number of solutions,
and that's why you're
getting integers.
It just took
overnight for Michael
to say, yeah, we can write
down a formula for all that.
And that started
our collaboration
on the index theorem.
And actually, nine
months from the time
he asked me the
question, at that time
we had a complete proof
of the index theorem.
INTERVIEWER: You had a new baby.
SINGER: What a baby.
It grew into really something--
very robust development.
INTERVIEWER: So as someone
you know without a science
background, is there a way
you can explain the theorem
in kind of lay terms?
And I understand if
that's not possible.
SINGER: Well, it's
difficult to do.
I can just give you motivation
for it, to some extent.
You're trying to
solve an equation,
and you want to
find the solution.
Something called the
phantom alternative,
where you look at the number
of solutions and you also look
at the number of different
ways you cannot get a solution.
And you compare the
difference of the two.
What you'd really like is
to have that equal to zero,
and that difference is called
the index of this equation.
You'd like it to be the
zero, because then it
would say that existence
implies uniqueness,
and uniqueness
implies existence.
Existence is-- well, any rate,
those are the two integers.
If they're equal, then
you know, as I said,
existence implies uniqueness.
Uniqueness implies existence.
Well, it's much easier
to show uniqueness
than there is existence.
So if you know
it's zero, you only
have to solve half the problem.
And you only solve the
easier half of the problem.
And that was the
original motivation
for defining or saying what
you meant by the index.
And the reason our
theorem was so exciting,
aside from the fact
that it combined
a lot of different
fields, is it gave you
an answer in geometric terms--
the number of solutions,
or the number of holes
in this particular, you see.
So it put geometry into this
partial differential equation
answer.
And that's what
made it exciting.
INTERVIEWER: Can
you explain how that
led to this sort of
breakdown between fields,
between physics and
math, for example?
SINGER: Well, there are
two questions, I think,
when you say the
breakdown between.
One is in mathematics itself.
This had such impact because we
were using geometry, topology,
a little algebraic geometry,
and analysis all together
to get a very striking solution.
So that broke down barriers
between fields a great deal.
And because it was so
striking, those barriers
have stayed down all this time,
except for people who were very
fixed in a given subject.
Physics is another matter,
because string theory
came along.
And it turns out, they needed
some aspects of mathematics
in order to solve their
problem, what's called K-theory.
And ultimately, they needed
the index theorem and K-theory
to be able to answer some
questions in string theory.
And so it turns out, very
quickly, young physicists
move rapidly and absorb
mathematics very rapidly.
So they became experts in
K-theory and the index theorem
very quickly.
And asked penetrating questions
about the subject, again,
very quickly.
It's interesting that Atiyah and
I wrote our last paper in '84,
and it was on the
applications of index theorem
to string theory.
Anomalies, let's
call, a cancellation
of anomalies in physics.
And we had a geometric
way or mathematical way
of explaining how those
anomalies came about
and how to eliminate them, and
that's what physicists wanted.
INTERVIEWER: Do you
think it was-- you know,
was it your particular exposure
and background in geometry,
starting at the University
of Chicago, that helped you
to see this in a different way?
Do you know what
it was that allowed
you to figure this out when
no one else had done it up
to that point?
SINGER: Well, I would say what
allowed me to make progress
on all these things was,
as I said originally,
I loved the interconnections
between fields.
I found that most exciting.
So I was well trained at
Chicago between the analysis
and geometry that I
had learned there.
And we had a very
good topology group
headed by George Whitehead.
And I learned a lot
of topology then.
So it was those connections that
allow me to put them together
when needed.
I mean, it just happened.
You're sitting on a park
bench-- it's the old story--
and suddenly it clicked.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah,
it's a great image.
Because as you pass people in a
park and you see them on a park
bench, you don't figure they're
necessarily thinking about
science-changing theorems, but--
SINGER: Well, I was
noted for sitting
on a park bench with
pencil and a pad of
ruled paper all the time.
INTERVIEWER: As
you look forward,
do you have expectations
for other things
that you think this
will help to explain
or unlock in the future?
Or could it be anything?
SINGER: Well, it turns
out that index theory
is used in a number of
different ways in physics.
I hesitated because
there's a subject called
noncommutative geometry,
which is too complicated
to explain here.
But I feel that index
theory has influenced that.
And I want to use some aspects
of non-Euclidean geometry
in the future to
explain some things that
are going on with black holes.
So I'm still interested
in physics and problems
in physics, but I want to use
more sophisticated methods
than are presently
available in physics
to attack those problems.
It's one of the
reasons I am retiring,
is so I can focus
on that material
without any complications.
INTERVIEWER: By sort of
uniting physics and mathematics
in a way that they hadn't been
before, what kinds of issues
have people subsequently been
able to deal with that they
couldn't have dealt with
without that closer connection?
SINGER: Well, for
example, index theory
is used to explain
entropy and black holes.
To compute certain kinds of
black holes and their entropy,
you have to use a
number of solutions
to a differential
equation for the entropy.
So there's an application
that was kind of unexpected.
Steve Hawking
talked about entropy
in a recent video on TV.
I think I'm hesitating,
because I'm just
going to repeat myself.
I think there are
parts of mathematics,
like noncommutative
geometry, that
have had some impact
on physics, but I
think it'll have more
so on black holes.
And that's one of
many subjects I
want to look into
in the near future.
There are some
aspects of topology--
it's gotten very
sophisticated, again,
partly because of index theory--
that tries to
combine string theory
with rather axiomatic
topology, I would call it.
And I think that's going to
have some impact on physics,
as well.
These are coming
subjects that I'm just
guessing about, really.
INTERVIEWER: But back when you
came up with the index theorem,
you didn't really know, at that
point, all of the ramifications
that it would have?
SINGER: No.
That theorem was-- you
know, 40 years of it.
It's always been robust.
Even now, we're working on--
my colleagues and I--
I'm going to come back to
talk to them-- are working
on some aspects of a rather
sophisticated index theorem
that nobody's
played with before.
INTERVIEWER: That must be
quite an accomplishment,
to feel that you have sort of
a long-term contribution that
keeps kind of giving
birth to new--
SINGER: Yes.
I'm very lucky in that way.
INTERVIEWER: I read that
you've made some comments
about the frustration of
communicating with younger
mathematicians about jargon.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: I wonder if
you could explain that.
SINGER: Every field
has its terminology--
not just in mathematics,
but whatever.
You're not really in
the field until you
understand the jargon.
In mathematics, that jargon
plays an important role,
particularly for young people to
feel they're part of the field.
Whereas, as an old
timer, naturally, I'm
not good at learning
other languages anyway,
so I am unhappy
with that jargon.
And I'm unhappy when young
people try and explain
something in that jargon.
And so, if anything, I just
trying to eliminate and ask,
now, what are you
really talking about?
Can you put it in more
straightforward terms
or give me an example
of what you mean?
So I'm impatient about that,
and not just with young people,
but it's true with many experts.
For example, the difference
between a good colloquium
lecture and a poor one is
whether the speaker uses jargon
or not.
INTERVIEWER: And as someone
who works in communications,
I completely agree with you.
It's the difference
between talking to impress
or talking to communicate.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: And
there is a difference.
SINGER: Absolutely.
INTERVIEWER: Let me ask a little
about some of your other work.
You were chair of the Committee
of Science and Public Policy
at the National
Academy of Science.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: Can you
talk a little about that?
SINGER: That was a
very exciting period
for me, my period in Washington,
and that's part of what I did.
We attacked a
number of problems.
One of the things we
did was describe--
I think it was the first
report on what to do
with nuclear waste that we had.
I had one experience where, with
the internet and computers just
breaking out, I had a
meeting where we discussed
privacy matters and
the threat to privacy
with what was coming.
But I was way ahead of my time.
Nobody on the committee
really went along
with that as going to happen.
I mention that because
now we're quite concerned
about that privacy.
But I was, I don't know,
20-odd years ahead of the game.
But the important
thing for me was I
met so many brilliant,
creative people there,
and it was exciting to be
with them all the time.
And they made me aware of how
creative human beings can be
and how constructive
they can be.
We were very careful--
my secretary and I-- in
choosing people who might serve.
And we had terrific people.
And to tell you another
story, you know,
I knew Jerry Wiesner from
first year I was here.
He was running the
electronic lab at the time.
And I came to see him because
I had an idea, based on Norbert
Wiener, of putting a multiple
probe on the optic nerve
and using it as a television
set for people who were blind.
And they looked at me
then and said, well, we
can only put one probe in now.
But if you want to come
and work in my laboratory,
you have a job, which is
how we met and talked.
But anyway, when he
was president of MIT,
I went to see him
about something else.
And he congratulated
me on being the chair.
And I was sheepishly
saying it would take away
from my research.
And he said, no, it won't, Is.
The experience
and the broadening
that you'll get then, when
you go back to mathematics,
you'll have an
entirely different view
about what you want to do
and how you want to do it.
He was absolutely right.
INTERVIEWER: How did it change?
How did that view change
by your experience?
SINGER: I simply
instead of focusing
on the technical aspects of
the problem I was working on,
I just took a step back and
said, do I want to do this?
Why do I want to do this?
Where does it fit in
my view of mathematics?
And often, that changed
how I went about things.
INTERVIEWER: How
about your experience
of being on the White
House Science Council?
SINGER: That was very exciting.
I can't speak much about that.
I think much of it is
still confidential.
But again, that was a
learning experience.
Again, there were
terrific people on that--
Paul Gray, for example.
And we have to talk about the
various presidents of MIT.
We haven't talked much about
MIT, per se, but we should.
INTERVIEWER: We will.
SINGER: Okay.
We didn't focus on much
of Reagan's program
as president for the country.
It was mostly
problems international
that one was concerned
with, I can't go into.
But I will mention one
that came up at that time.
That's when one discovered AIDS.
And we had to discuss
with the science advisor
how he would approach
the president
with this horrendous problem.
And President Reagan was very
positive about the whole thing.
He said, well--
what we suggested
is he get a committee
to look into it
and make recommendations.
And he said immediately he
had no prejudices of any sort.
Yes, let's do that
immediately, and let's see
what we come up with.
And the first thing they came
up with, which was important,
was to emphasize cleanliness
was the first recommendation
of the committee.
And I think they
did a very good job.
You know, that's an
example of something
that came our way
from time to time.
INTERVIEWER: Was
it important to you
to just sort of put in this
time in the public sector?
SINGER: The part in the
academy was important.
I learned a great deal there.
And being on the White
House Science Council
was just one of those
things that I felt, well,
I feel I'm a pretty
level-headed guy.
If I can be useful to them--
I don't know why they
want a mathematician,
but if I can be useful to
them, then, by all means,
I have to do it, just as a
citizen more than anything.
And in fact, I remember the
science advisor one morning,
after a heavy meeting the night
before, coming in and said,
Is, your suggestion
solves the problem.
How can you be so smart?
You're just a mathematician.
I said, so?
You could see the
role of mathematics
in that heady environment.
INTERVIEWER: Did you get any
sort of different perspective
from that experience in DC
that you brought back in
and it somehow contributed
to what you did back at MIT?
Or was it more an issue
of personal growth?
SINGER: I don't
think it's growth,
but I think there is a
different perspective.
For example, as I've mentioned,
I served in the armed forces
her almost three years.
And I had a certain perspective
about the armed forces.
I like my freedom,
and in that respect,
I hated being
incarcerated, so to speak.
But I gained a healthy
respect for the armed forces,
the generals I talked to who
came to various meetings who
were necessary.
I had lunch with a general
whose responsibility
would be to push the
button if we were
going to use nuclear weapons.
And I said to myself then that
their choice was impeccable.
In general, I concluded
that their choice
of people and how they go
about it is remarkable--
much better than the
way we choose people
for tenure and stuff like that.
They were remarkable.
And the generals, I'd have
lunch with from time to time.
Often, we would have
to go to the cafeteria
because there wasn't enough
food around for them.
You know, the White House
Council would have lunch,
but nobody else could
who was visiting.
And I elected to go to the
cafeteria with our visitors,
often.
I have a lot of respect for
the military on the basis
of what I learned at that time.
And I got a better feeling
for the chain of command
that occurs in the White
House at that time.
INTERVIEWER: Is the difference--
and this is only a
guess on my part.
Is the difference that they're
able to look at and evaluate
more almost intangible
qualities than might be involved
in the decision for tenure?
They're looking more at
what the person contributes
as an individual.
SINGER: I don't know
the answer to that.
I can only say that there's
so many little things that
made me come to the conclusion.
For example, the aid
to the science advisor,
Jake [INAUDIBLE],, had been in
charge of a nuclear submarine
before that.
Well, you can imagine
when we were to meet,
there was always one crisis--
I mentioned one or two--
coming up all the time.
I don't think I've ever met
a person as cool as he was.
There was no crisis that
he couldn't have something
constructive to say
about how to handle it,
and all in a cool manner.
And as I said, that
was the feeling
I had about the general, who
would have to push the bomb.
It's those individuals
and their personalities
that led me to believe that
the selection process must
be awfully good.
Sheila Widnall, I
think, will confirm
that, because she was
Secretary of the Navy, was it?
And I think she'll confirm
that sense of selection
that they have that's
better than ours.
INTERVIEWER: You were a Sloan
Fellow and a Guggenheim Fellow
two times.
Is there anything about the
experience, that opportunity,
that you'd want to talk about?
SINGER: Could you
repeat the question?
INTERVIEWER: You
were a Sloan Fellow--
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: --and a
Guggenheim Fellow two times.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: What does
that experience add?
SINGER: Well, the
main thing is freedom.
I think all research people want
the freedom to do their work.
And they gave me a
great deal of freedom
so that I could just
do what I wanted.
And I'm very indebted
to those foundations
for allowing me the freedom
to do what I wanted.
INTERVIEWER: Freedom is a theme.
SINGER: It's the theme, yes.
INTERVIEWER: You've been
teaching first semester
calculus all along, haven't you?
SINGER: Not all along.
That's very interesting.
Well, since you brought up
teaching, I had occasion--
I was looking for old
notes of mine of a lecture
I gave a long time ago.
What I found was a
series of courses
that I had given in large
classrooms and the revision
of the subjects--
including, at the beginning,
teaching calculus.
We all taught
calculus at that time.
But for many years, I only
taught graduate courses
or the high-level
undergraduate courses.
I don't know what
possessed me, but I
decided to be a TA in the first
calculus course to freshmen.
I think I did it because my good
friend ran the whole program
one year.
I think what motivated me was
I was too far removed from MIT
on the undergraduate level.
And this gave me a
chance to come back.
And in fact, it was a wonderful
experience the two years
that I did it, making
contact with freshmen again.
They liked my lecturing.
And in fact, whoever
ran the program
had instructors who were from
abroad to come in and listen
to how I handled the course.
One of the important
things that happened--
Arthur Mattuck was in charge
of the calculus program.
He is a fantastically good
lecturer-- showman, really.
And he arranged, at one
time I was doing that,
that we TAs would not be
responsible for final exams
or making up
problems or grading.
And that changed
our relationship
with the undergraduates,
with the freshmen,
because we were now their
friend and not judging them.
And I'd often come
in and say, well,
what did so-and-so do
this year, this time?
They'd say, and I'd
say, well, that's not
the way to go about it.
I think, really, to see
it, you do it this way.
So there was that
sense of freedom
that I could say
what I wanted it.
And the students understood
that I was there to help them
and not to judge.
I'm repeating myself.
And that was an entirely
good relationship.
Moreover, I got to know some
of the students quite well.
And in every class,
freshman class, at least two
of the students could be
world-famous scientists,
engineers, anything
they wanted to do.
They were that good.
Many of them elected
to do other things.
So it was very personal
experience for me,
and I had made friends.
I saw kids who seemed
to have nothing
grow to show a great deal.
And that made it such a
exciting, different experience.
It made me feel part of MIT that
I hadn't felt for many years.
Everybody was surprised that
I did it a couple of times.
INTERVIEWER: Do you have
a philosophy of teaching?
Or how does sort of teaching
integrate with your other work?
SINGER: Teaching is integrated
with my other work in the sense
that I never think of
research in quotation marks.
All I want to do is
understand what's going on.
And the motivation
for understanding
is when I understand it, then
I can explain it to somebody.
So there's a link for me
between doing research--
doing research means
understanding something
that I don't understand,
and maybe it turns out
nobody else understands.
And when I do
understand it, the link
is I want to tell them about it.
So therefore, in a sense,
I'm a good teacher.
I can put myself in the
position of a student.
I know what they
don't understand,
and now, if I know
them well enough,
I can kind of explain what
they don't understand in terms
that they can comprehend.
So it's that empathy that I have
that makes me a good teacher.
INTERVIEWER: Do you
learn from your students?
SINGER: Rarely.
On the graduate level,
I have learned a lot
from my graduate students.
On the undergraduate level, no.
INTERVIEWER: You've had a
number of visiting appointments
at UCLA and Columbia
and Princeton,
and you were at Berkeley.
When you go off and spend time
at other academic institutions,
does that come back in
any way and benefit MIT?
Is there a value from
those experiences?
SINGER: Well, of course, all
experiences are valuable.
Every day is valuable.
But no, I'm impressed with MIT.
We do things right--
not just in the math department.
I'm really impressed with how
constructive everybody is here.
And I think we do a better job
than anywhere else that I know.
So I haven't learned
anything from other schools
that we need to know at MIT.
INTERVIEWER: Well, that's an
important lesson right there.
SINGER: Yes, I think so.
INTERVIEWER: Were
you surprised to be
chosen an Institute Professor?
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: Tell me why.
SINGER: Well, it just
never occurred to me.
I talked to Paul Gray
about it recently.
And he said one of
the joys for him
as president was
to notify people.
And he talked about
one case where
the professor came in
shaking and said immediately,
what have I done wrong?
What have I done wrong?
And I confessed to Paul
that when I came to see him,
that was what I felt, that I
had been called in because I'd
done something wrong.
But I kept my mouth shut.
So I was shocked, delighted,
of course, when he told me.
INTERVIEWER: How has it changed
the nature of your relationship
with MIT, if at all?
SINGER: It changed
my relationship
with the math department
a lot, because it
meant I reported
directly to the provost
and that I was free
to do what I wanted.
And again, that freedom
meant a great deal to me.
My math physics seminar
was mostly on my mind.
And I spent most of my time
making sure that that ran well.
And more recently,
we had a new seminar
called New Opportunities for
Mathematics in Other Fields,
where we got visitors
from other fields
to talk about possible
connections with mathematics.
I did that for a
year and a half,
and that was very
exciting, also.
Again, I learned a great
deal from these people.
We'd go out to
dinner, and I'd be
talking to people
who are experts
in an entirely different
field, and that was exciting.
INTERVIEWER: That's what
I'm doing over here.
It's great fun.
SINGER: Yes.
Okay.
INTERVIEWER: You have a list
of some incredibly prestigious
awards and honors, and I'm
wondering if any in particular
have meant more than the others
or were very meaningful to you?
SINGER: Well, the Abel Prize
was the most prestigious.
And I think, because of
that, it means more to me.
You know, the Atiyah-Singer
index theorem--
Michael and I won
the prize together.
The Atiyah-Singer
index theorem did have
an impact over some 40 years.
It's still having an impact.
And to have that
recognized and recognized
throughout the world, not just
in the mathematical world,
I thought was very
important for mathematics
and certainly important for
me in the sense that I feel--
I don't know.
I can't express how
I feel about it.
INTERVIEWER: Let's
talk about MIT.
SINGER: Yes?
INTERVIEWER: Why have
you stayed here so long?
What is it about your career
interests, your research
interests that have meshed so
well with the environment here?
SINGER: Why have I
stayed here so long?
I think I'll expand on
it, but the direct answer
is, it's the best place to be.
And the issue is why.
We talked about freedom,
and that's part of it.
But I think the--
let me put it this way.
The Japanese have
a game, and when
they want to evaluate what a
person is or their character,
the game is to say
one word to do that.
For x, its energy.
For someone else, it's depth.
For me, the one word
for MIT is generosity.
It's a generous place.
For me, it's been
a generous place.
Freedom is part of
that generosity.
It's a place where I
grew up scientifically.
Remind you of my background--
I came as a grad student after
almost three years in the army.
I was way behind.
I came here and got involved
in what we were doing.
And gradually, as time went--
and you know, I had to go away,
and then I came back.
Gradually, as time went on,
even before the index theorem,
it sort of became clear--
we went out to lunch,
did one thing or another,
that questions would come up.
And after a while, I'd
say, well, maybe we
were looking at it wrong.
Maybe we should
look at it this way.
And it changed our
picture of the issue.
And after a time,
there'd be a discussion
and there'd be silence, and
everybody would turn to me.
And it's in that sense that
I kind of grew up at MIT.
And then I had the freedom, soon
enough, to do what I wanted,
even before the index theorem
because I was a good lecturer.
I would do things
differently than others,
and that was much appreciated.
That generosity shows
up in a lot of ways.
OpenCourseWare, as
my great example,
started as a recommendation by
some faculty members and others
working hard on
their courses so it
would aid their
administration, finding funds
to have it happen.
That's a great
reflection of MIT,
per se, as to what we're about.
And I've always found the
administration very eager
to allow faculty and
students the freedom
to do something
constructive and different.
There was no reason to leave
a place as wonderful as that.
INTERVIEWER: I guess
maybe we should--
let's talk about the presidents.
SINGER: All right.
INTERVIEWER: And
I'll leave it to you.
Who would you like to speak
about or make a comment about?
SINGER: Well, I've been
fortunate in getting
to know them all pretty well.
Howard Johnson comes to
mind because of his death
such a short time ago.
I got to know him because
we had student unrest here,
you know, for a period of time.
I wrote him a note saying
that on the basis of what
I knew about Berkeley,
he would be wise
if he kept in contact
with the faculty
during all the commotion,
excitement that's going on.
And he did better than that.
He had two committees--
a faculty advisory group and
a student advisory group.
FAG and SAG we called
it at the time.
And we met frequently
and were made
aware of what the issues-- there
were always a crisis coming up
all the time.
So that was something special.
And when it was over with,
we had a party at our house
for Howard.
And since then, we've
become very good friends.
That's one example of
something that happened.
Paul Gray-- I don't think
people realize how much
Paul and Priscilla
did for MIT in terms
of supporting the
search for women
to come here, making it a more
amenable place for everybody.
In my case, I got
involved in trying
to get African
Americans here, again,
through Paul's push and our
chair at the time, Ken Hoffman.
So on several occasions--
for example, I think I
gave a talk at Georgia Tech
and used the occasion to visit
a technical school for African
Americans, an
engineering school.
And I went there and talked
to the dean of science
and the members of the faculty.
It's very funny, if
you want a story.
I've given this talk
at Georgia Tech.
And I had this appointment,
but we played tennis
first afterward.
And so I ended up at the
campus with my tennis racquet,
luckily, because those
were difficult moments
between places, between African
Americans and Caucasians.
And I walked on the campus,
and the first look of students
was a glare at me.
But then they saw my
tennis racket and smiled.
So that was my entree.
And I went to talk to
the math department.
The dean was there.
He was very antagonistic,
because he thought, somehow,
MIT was trying to take
away some of his power.
And that was unpleasant,
the discussion we had,
going nowhere.
He was just
protecting his power.
He left, and then
the faculty relaxed,
and we had a very nice chat.
They were very pleased to have
someone of my stature come down
and talk to them.
Another occasion,
which did work well,
was I went to Howard University.
And I had talked to
our chair, Ken Hoffman,
who urged me to go.
Our trouble with getting
African Americans is they
don't want their best
students to come to MIT.
They want to keep them.
And I suggested
that maybe we could
have them come during
their junior year
and then go back for
their senior year
and report on their
experiences at MIT.
And that would be constructive.
And so I went,
and it worked out.
We had two women come up.
I only kept track for a
while with one of them.
And she had a
terrific experience
and played around, became
head of a company or a leader
in some administrative
capacity down in the South.
I've lost track of it.
But sort of always knowing
that Paul and Priscilla were
behind many of these things.
And now we're just good
friends as a result of that.
Chuck Vest and I became
good friends, as well,
because he comes from Michigan.
And that's where I went, to
the University of Michigan.
So I talked to him a lot.
He invited me to--
he asked me--
I've forgotten who is going
to be the new inauguration
or new president at the
University of Michigan.
But he asked me to represent
MIT at that inauguration.
I was pleased to do that.
Nice to get back to
home base, so to speak.
And I've told you,
Jerry Wiesner and I,
I've known him from way back.
I'd always consult with
him, and he was always
so positive and constructive
about everything.
INTERVIEWER: Did you ever have
an interest in administration?
SINGER: No.
No, not at all.
I've been lucky to avoid
it, except for the big chair
of this committee in Washington,
and I had a very good staff
who took care of everything.
Of course, I was on the search
committee for Susan Hockfield.
And we had a-- just when
she came and talked to us,
I felt we were close friends
the moment she talked about what
her ideas were for MIT.
have I left anybody out
in that period of time?
INTERVIEWER: I don't think so.
SINGER: I don't think so, yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Who was
president when you arrived?
Was that Howard Johnson?
SINGER: No, it was before that.
Someone I didn't know then.
INTERVIEWER: Okay.
Let me ask a little about
the School of Science.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: I'm
wondering if you
have any thoughts about
what its strengths are
or its role at MIT?
Your impressions of
the school itself.
SINGER: Well, I've
known a couple of deans.
They've been terrific.
Mark's a terrific dean.
I don't really
have any comments.
And I make a lot of contact
with the physics department,
because of my math
physics seminar.
They have a very strong faculty.
And their postdocs
are very good now.
They weren't for a while,
but they are very good now.
And I've seen some
of the people grow
and are really an integral
part of the faculty.
So those are the only
two departments I know.
I don't know biology,
really, at all.
INTERVIEWER: What makes a good
graduate student or a postdoc?
SINGER: Well, for
me, it's, again,
the interface between
fields and the eagerness
to understand what's
going on between fields.
And I have people out there
who are in that category now
in physics.
INTERVIEWER: How about the
strengths of the mathematics
department?
SINGER: Well, it came in first
in the popularity ratings
this year, and it
did five years ago.
And I think rightly so.
And this means not
tied first, but first.
And that shows that we're
recognized for its strength.
One of the things that's
happened in our department
is attention to
the undergraduates
and preparing them for these
various competitions, which
they more or less win
or are close to winning.
And that created
an understanding
with high school students
that MIT was the place to go.
And so we've been
very lucky that we
get finalists in
various competitions
for high school coming to MIT.
So the MIT undergraduate
program right now,
although I'm not
part of it at all,
they have to take
into account that they
have brilliant kids coming
in who are ready for anything
when they arrive and are
well advanced beyond anything
that we've really seen.
We may see it in one or
two students in the past,
but now it's common for
those undergraduates.
And our grad students
who come, they're
just excited about coming
here because there's
so much going on.
So we've benefited
by that combination
of exciting undergrads,
grad students now.
Much better program of
students we have now
than we had, say, 10 years ago.
My criteria was where do they
go after they get their PhD.
Where do they end up?
Didn't look too good before.
Now it's looking much better.
INTERVIEWER: Since you
have the perspective
of being here for
a long time, can we
talk a little bit about the
changes that you've seen?
How about in the culture?
Has that changed in the
time that you've been here?
SINGER: I don't really know what
culture means in this context.
The only thing I've
noticed is that students
have much more say
in what's happening
at MIT than they used to.
I think that's all
for the better.
And they also have a
different attitude.
When I first came to
MIT, it was very strict,
and they did what
they were told.
They'd better do it or
else, that kind of a "tech
is hell" was not there,
but the reflections of it,
the relics of it were there.
Now, that's not true at all.
Students have a lot to
say about what's going on.
They have much more flexibility.
That's part of the
generosity I'm talking about,
flexible to do what they want.
We've learned that a student
may come in with an idea
that they're going
to major in field x,
and they end up doing
something entirely different
and have different
aims and interests
by the time of
their second year.
And having learned that, it's
been built into the program.
So we're much more flexible
and much more generous
than we used to be.
Europe, for example, is
something that was not there
a long time ago.
And that's another
example of generosity,
of taking people who
are kids, really,
and spending some
time with them.
And I don't do that, but
a lot of my colleagues do.
And I think it's a
very important program.
It does a lot for the student.
And in fact, students
have become so good,
it also does a lot for
the faculty member,
especially in laboratories.
INTERVIEWER: Why
do you think it's
so much better for
students to have a greater
say in what's going on at MIT?
SINGER: I think
they're pretty astute.
And so when they see
things that are wrong,
they now can speak
up about it in a way
that they hadn't before.
So, for example, going back
to when I taught, I was TA,
students in my class would
invite me to some event--
lunch, dinner,
something like that.
And they would talk freely
about the difference
between MIT and Harvard in a way
that didn't happen years ago.
So they're astute.
They're constructive.
So their insights are important.
INTERVIEWER: How about
changes that you've
seen in the faculty?
SINGER: I don't see much
difference, actually.
What I see that's
different is the climate
in which they're in.
But I don't see
them any different.
I think they are as focused
in a combination of research
and teaching as we
were earlier on.
I don't see much difference.
The one real big difference is
certainly the women in the math
faculty are very gung-ho about
making sure that women are well
represented in the field.
And they have lectures
by women on mathematics.
They're also probably
more socially oriented
than we were years ago,
but in a different way.
So the changes there
are simple enough.
We were very socially
bound in the sense
that we would have a party
after every colloquium,
and wives would
come to that party.
And we got to know
everybody quite well.
Now, of course, that's
changed a great deal,
because women work much
more independently, where
there are no such parties.
There are too many
colloquia anyway,
so we couldn't keep that up.
And so that's been separated,
and the sociability
occurs in different ways.
INTERVIEWER: Has the increase
in women in your department,
has it changed the
department in ways?
SINGER: I think it has.
INTERVIEWER: In what ways?
Can you speak to that at all?
SINGER: Well, though I haven't
spoken to any students,
I'm sure that women students
feel much more comfortable,
because they have women they
can come and talk to, which
was difficult a long time ago.
I think there's more
sociability in the department
than there was before--
more parties, more
celebrations, more contacts
in the department as
opposed to parties
had somebody's house,
as there were years ago.
INTERVIEWER: Have you seen
MIT change academically
over the years in
any significant way?
SINGER: Greater
interconnection between fields.
Biotech, for
example, is something
that's very important
that's fairly new
and I don't know much about.
I think the interaction
between departments
is increasing rapidly.
It's one thing I tried to
promote in this seminar I had.
INTERVIEWER: It does seem
to be a trend academically.
SINGER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: Any institutional
turning points that you've seen
or that you want to speak to?
SINGER: I wouldn't know
anything about that.
As I told you, I've
avoided all that.
It's not my bag.
INTERVIEWER: What things
have we not talked
about that you think
are important to say?
Can be anything about your
own research, about MIT,
about your hopes for
MIT in the future.
SINGER: I think we've covered
everything that I can imagine.
I'd just like to
say that I've been
very fortunate in the
support I've gotten from MIT
and growing up here at
MIT and having the freedom
and opportunity to do the
things I want int mathematics.
And fortunate that I
feel confident that I
can continue doing it.
INTERVIEWER: So what will
you be working on after June?
SINGER: My tennis game, for one.
But I mentioned that
I think something
can be said about
black holes that
involve a new form of geometry,
noncommutative geometry.
Again, there are
some connections
between topology
analysis and geometry
that haven't been pursued by
others that I think I can have
something interesting to say.
The main thing is I can
afford to gamble, you know?
Why not?
And I will gamble, and
I'll enjoy doing that.
INTERVIEWER: That's what you're
supposed to do when you retire.
SINGER: I see.
Okay.
INTERVIEWER: Thank you so much.
SINGER: Thank you.
It's my pleasure.
INTERVIEWER: It's been a
pleasure to talk to you.